how does it all begin this stepping stone career
that leads to super stardom in
the major hockey arenas in North
America Peak Interest is centered around the
annual draft of players the Buffalo Sabers
have the pleasure and honor of selecting
Pierre ton the New Jersey Devil select
Brendan Shanahan Joel Thon Patrick Marlo
Alexander oet MCNY malol Steven stamp go
Drew dowy John T Victor headman Nathan mckin
Alexander bar Conor mcav Jack Austin Matthew
Patrick l I hear myself often say I love
the game of hockey and I do I still love the
game in front to Milo he scores
are you kidding me with that
pass it goes in and he scores kkin rips he [Music]
[Applause] scores a magical year a
magical moment that you'll remember
forever and more heartbreak in the Stanley
Cup Playoffs oh my goodness what a
debut here's number two L shoots he
St not a shot by Patrick Marlo Mr San Jose
Shark they score Jo simply Sensational SC number
60 for Steven stos what a brilliant goal by Nathan
mcken what can you say what a [Music] goal
and with the first overall selection in the
2023 NHL draft with our first selection we are
proud to select Conor Bard Neil Carlson there
are thousands of youngsters in this land
who want to play hockey Leo congrats bro
too score score it's a hatrick for Leo badar
takes the BL scores what a goal by con [Music]
vard this stepping stone career
how does it all [Applause]
begin